e
n'est pas qu'il y a trop de
patients pour le moment de la
saison. C'est plutôt qu'il y a
trop peu de personnel soignant.
- Elles arrivent tour à tour.
- On en compte à peu près
sept en haut.
- Même les ambulances ont
de la difficulté à se frayer
un chemin jusqu'aux urgences
de l'hôpital Pierre-Le-Gardeur,
à Terrebonne.
STÉPHANE CORMIER, prés., Synd.
interprof. de Lanaudière (FIQ)
- Il y a une infirmière qui faut
qu'elle les voie les sept.
Il y en a une qui est atitrée
pour ça. Souvent, c'est des
patients qui ne vont pas bien.
C'est des temps difficiles pour
nos urgences dans Lanaudière.
- Ça semble être complétement
plein. C'est des civières
un petit peu partout
dans les corridors.
es corridors, loin
des caméras, il y a une femme
atteinte de sclérose en plaques
qui attend depuis plus de
24 heures, couchée sur un petit
banc, en douleur. Une autre
qui s'est fait dire qu'en raiso,
elle devait attendre plus
de 20 heures. C'est à ça
que ressemble, une urgence
occupée à plus de 200 %.
CATHERINE PERREAULT, infirmière
l Pierre-Le Gardeur
- Les personnes qui viennent
et qui sont couchées dans nos
civières, elles sont vraiment
malades. Elles ont
besoin de nos soins.
- Et la situation est loin
d'être unique à Terrebonne.
Un peu partout au Québec,
l'histoire se répète depuis
des semaines, maintenant :
les urgences débordent
et manquent de personnel.
Dr GILBERT BOUCHER, prés., Asso.
spécialistes médecine d'urgence
- Une fois qu'on dépasse 150 %,
tout devient très
disfonctionnel. On retient
les ambulances. On peut prendre
jusqu'à 20 minutes juste
pour trouver une civière
à un patient. Il y a énormément
de Québécois qui viennent sonner
à nos portes et qui repartent
sans voir de médecin.
- C'est justement ce qui est
arrivé en fin de semaine à un
septuagénaire, qui a attendu
16 heures à l'urgence sans voir
le médecin. Le lendemain, il
s'est rendu à un autre hôpital
et serait décédé des suites
d'un anévrisme. Un cas abandonné
par le système, selon cert
médecins, loin d'être unique.
Environ 40 % des patients
quitteraient sans avoir vu un
médecin, selon le Dr. Boucher.
- Je peux vous parler de cas qui
ont été dans d'autres hôpitaux
où ils voient l'infirmière
de triage, font un ou deux
tests, ne peuvent pas voir
de médecin et quittent. Et nous,
on les vres plus tres plus tres,
et oui, ils ont eu une crise
cardiaque; oui, ils ont eu
des infections de manquées,
il y a des choses qui arrivent.
C'est ma
Le triage, ce n'est pas fait...
ce n'est pas une manière
de traiter les gens.
Le triage, c'est une manière
de priorens.
- C'est sûr qu'on va prioriser,
mais à un moment donné, c'est
la priorité de la priorité
de la priorité, puis là,
les qui paient le prix
au bout de la ligne.
- Elles, ce sont les infirmières
au triage, sous pression,
parfois en nombre insuffisantà s
alors que les heures d'attente
ne font que s'allonger.
Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Ter